but we start tonight with something I
couldn't believe this story when it
broke late today truly out of this world
it's hard to think of anything that
frankly is more significant than this
tonight according to what is now an
explosive expose in the publication the
debrief a former Intel official turned
whistleblower has given Congress and the
Intel Community Inspector General
extensive classified information about
deeply covert programs that he says
possess retrieved and intact and
partially intact craft of non-human
origin
now this whistleblower is not some coke
his name is David Charles grosh and he's
a decorated former combat officer in
Afghanistan as well as a veteran of the
national geospatial Intel agency and the
national reconnaissance office now it
was in that office where he served as
the representative to the unidentified
aerial phenomena task force
here he is in his own words
when you say crash retrieval what do you
mean
these are retrieving non-human origin
technical Vehicles you know call it
spacecraft if you will it's probably not
the right parlance but uh no kidding
non-human exotic origin vehicles that
have either landed or crashed
are they electric vehicles no but like
other whistleblowers we've heard from of
late the government bureaucracy will
undoubtedly try to discredit Mr grisha's
account but anticipating the Fallout
he's warning that such ongoing
government denial of this 80-year arms
race what he calls it would be extremely
dangerous for mankind inhibiting our
ability to be prepared for an unexpected
non-human intelligence contact scenario
joining us now is Ryan Graves a former
fa-18 Super Hornet pilot for the Navy
who says he came across these types of
aircraft
Ryan I mean I stopped I I was stopped
today at everything I was doing when
this came out late today but do you
agree this is at this point about safety
and our own National Security at this
point
oh absolutely it's never stopped being
about our national security what David
has been able to do and the courage that
he's been able to demonstrate coming
forward I think are exactly what
Congress was hoping for when they've
enacted laws in the last National
Defense authorization act in order to
enable just this
now what you saw when you were on the
F-18 when you were highlighting the F-18
describe for us specifically
certainly we were flying out off the
coast of Virginia Beach on a daily basis
and we started noticing on our radar on
our camera systems and eventually our
eyeballs what appeared to be dark gray
or black cubes inside of clear
translucent spheres these objects were
typically anywhere between 250 and 350
knots and Performing
Meandering Maneuvers or even straight
Maneuvers upwards of supersonic
this actually lines up quite well with
what Dr Sean Kirkpatrick of the all
domain anomaly resolution office
initially or has recently
communicated being the most prevalent
type of object that he's been seeing
through his research spherical objects
that travel anywhere from zero to two
Mach
now Ryan the government has has slowly
had to reveal that these are indeed
unidentified objects that they cannot
you know they they can't say what they
are but they're not regular
but their justification essentially for
not being forthright about this
initially was National Security correct
certainly not from the angle of we're
gonna hide what's on our camera systems
but the fact that our cameras could
perhaps see certain things or our Radars
could detect certain objects at certain
ranges that's typically the reason
that's been explained why these these
videos and these images have been
classified to the level they have been
yeah I'm sorry I want to play a little
bit more from this whistleblower than
let you finish your thought there
we have spacecraft from another species
we do yeah
how many
quite a number
Ryan again
this is the kind of stuff people would
just be waved off as a complete insane
asylum person for even speculating about
just you know recently a few years ago
but now it's like oh yeah there's a lot
of these
what is the average American supposed to
think about the government's credibility
on this issue given now what we're
discovering albeit you know belatedly
well I think that I think the average
person right now just needs to to sit
and wait a little bit and see this
process play out uh David has provided
uh a number of documents and pieces of
evidence to my knowledge uh that
Congress can then validate
uh and then they'll be in a position
then to communicate that information to
the American people I truly believe that
transparency is the only way this
conversation is going to be resolved
this is a great step forward in that
direction
well and certainly Congress has to be
briefed on this regularly I mean if you
can't keep this information from
Congress I don't believe there's any
justification for doing that Ryan I
can't wait to find out more thank you
very much for joining us tonight hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else